so where it begins where we're going to
begin is motion in a single dimension so
we remember I said up down right all
that's right we call this straight-line
motion because it's an object that moves
along a straight line and that that line
can be oriented however you like but the
important thing is you can only move
back and forth along that direction so
picture a straight line that straight
line could be up or down a left away
whatever you like but you're moving back
and forth along that okay this is the
only thing that as two units students we
have a look at under motion in
mathematics okay that's the only one big
idea however it's worth a displacement
velocity acceleration is such big ideas
that even though it's like follow that
all there is it's still a really
important and major part of the course
now as extension one students with it
extend down a little bit we say okay
just for a moment stay in a straight
line but if what you've got on your
straight line is moving in a very
particular predictable way we call it
simple harmonic motion this is the kind
of motion that you observe if you have
an object like saying a ball that floats
in a harbor or rather like a boat that
floats in a harbor and it's moving up
and down as the tide comes in and out
okay stop moving back and forth it's
anchored on the one spot but the tie in
itself is moving the boat up and down
okay so you still have worn a straight
line it's an up-down straight line okay
but it moves in is very predictable way
up and down up and down if you would
track this motion over time what you get
is a is a wave function basically okay
like literally a wave function okay so
that's why we have a look at
trigonometry in this context okay we're
gonna ask you something Thorin that is
not because when you when you do that
right when you're doing this you're not
moving on one axis anymore if you have a
look for example if you think about take
the end of my um my pencil okay it's
actually got up down motion and left
right motion so it's
two dimensions which is why that kind of
motion has to be covered is the next
thing which is I know right it's always
the key actually a projectile motion is
what happens always say okay look let's
forget this straight line now right in
the real world we can move far more
directions than that so project
evolution says okay if you throw objects
if you throw objects through the air or
you propel them you clearly are not just
going to get back and forth you're going
to get up and down there are lots of all
kinds of motion than that that
incorporate up down left right but this
is the most interesting and predictable
kind of um instance on it okay so simple
harmonic projectile motion these are
what comprise extension one motion now I
know it's a really violent or two thirds
of the room but since we're all
considering it together you guys will
have this all in one piece when we go
into mechanics which is an extension to
topic we're just going further down into
all of the details of what's going on so
the first thing is what we call
resistant mushroom so remember I said
okay an object is moving it has such and
such displacement such and such velocity
something to such as such acceleration
mechanics is trying to answer the
question of why is it doing that if
you've got an object and it is just
slowing down forever why is it doing
that well maybe it's in a medium like
air or like a muddy pond or something
like that that is slowing it down
constantly okay so resisted motion means
its motion it's being stopped or
resisted by something that's the first
thing the extension to inversion the
second thing which is not really one
thing it's as you see about some point
is called circular motion so this is
where you have objects that are moving
round and round and round so the first
thing is when you have we stay on if you
have a look at all of this at the moment
all this is in two dimensions okay it's
all in two dimensions this is up down
left right okay so when you've thrown
something through the air you got that
idea which stay on that plane that
two-dimensional plane we call this first
one this first kind of circular motion
uniform circular motion so that's an
object and it's moving around a track
picture a racing car and it's just going
round and round a perfect circular track
at the same speed all the time ok i will
talk about the ideas of lateral and
angular velocity in that case and then
we finally break it out from there and
say ok it's nice to figure out one
dimension because it's simple it's nice
that you have two dimensions because
more interesting there's more
interesting mathematics there but we
live in a three-dimensional world ok so
there are two final things that we
finish up we first call them the conical
pendulum so a normal pendulum is what
Nikita was talking about proportions and
borrow these headphones normal pendulum
like on a clock okay at all pendulum is
just sweet back and forth and so in fact
this is two-dimensional motion do you
see this right there's uptown moving
from from the distance for the ground
and it is left right like across from
fourth million that kind of thing a
conical pendulum says well what if you
move this pendulum and you add a
direction of motion back and forth
between you and me right if it moves in
fact in a kind of conical shape right so
this trace is our a cone which is why we
call it a conical pendulum okay so with
that extra third dimension and tension
along the stream that's holding it there
and grabbing all that kind of thing
that's what this is about one last one
and this is where we finish the last
part of motion in method is called Bank
tracks as you remember I told you about
a racing car that's going round and
round around a circular track in reality
if you're going that fast because your
way around and round around there are
your motion is actually pushing you out
towards the edge of the track right and
so your steering is all this friction on
your wheels again forces that we can
talk about later on in order to overcome
that and if you have a look if you
imagine a race in fact they actually
don't have a flat road they bank the
road so you're at an angle okay so what
happens is your car is actually racing
along and it's sort of you're actually
leading over now anyone who's ridden a
bike knows that if you're riding at any
decent speed if you want to turn you
cannot stay perfectly upright you
actually have to lean over to turn
around
softbank tracks i'm all about okay so
this is extension to measure okay and it
is called mechanics because interested
not just in how things are moving but
why they do